calm collected going into starfield's
launch and as long as they're gaining
Game Pass Subs maybe they don't care
um I completely agree though that you
want to put your best foot forward to me
as an Xbox fan it feels a little icky
that when a game goes exclusive and no
longer multi-plat we're still getting 30
frames and I feel like when you cut
those skus down and you're able to focus
on that one platform the expectation
from the consumer no matter the
technical complications which are beyond
the average consumer's knowledge set the
expectation coming in is I'm getting the
because you are giving to this me to me
exclusively on this platform I'm getting
the best possible version that was only
made through this collaboration of
Microsoft and Bethesda and especially
you know the problem Hi-Fi Rush puts
like a little asterisk next to this but
still but this is the first fully
marketed we've known about it for a
while there's been a build up to it
Bethesda first party game coming up